so I have a tip for you if you'll using
the anchor platform to share and
distribute your podcast then have a very
very quick tip which could get you more
listeners so what I've been doing when I
share my podcast what I've been doing is
I'll be sharing it on the Monday so when
I share it on the Monday I'll put it
across all with the other so shows that
I use Twitter LinkedIn Facebook and what
I've been doing to follow up with that
episode because obviously when you
initially share it it gets quite a lot
of traction and what anchor allows you
to do is create a video which they sort
of transcribe the audio and all that
sort of stuff and what I've been doing
is actually sharing that video so
probably maybe three four days after
I've initially released that episode so
basically you can actually make a short
video which anchor will produce for you
you have to go in to the anchor platform
I think you have to do it on the desktop
click on then transcribe my video which
you then do you might have to edit some
of the text that you say because it
doesn't always pick up the exact words
that you say and basically what then
happens is they pull it into the whole
format and they pull it into either a
square or it's wide or it's a bit longer
where it's actually a video of the audio
that you transcribed and it just
basically it's basically the subtitles
but the way that they do it
is super cool and it's actually quite
smart so what I'll do at the end of this
video as well is I'll include one of the
videos that I've done introducing the
podcast and I've then shared that video
and all the platforms wrote a little
post about it and sort of just try to
gain some more listeners and gamers
short snip it into the person that I'm
gonna be interviewing on my podcast so I
wanted to share that very quick tip I
feel like it's been working and
something that you should definitely be
utilizing if you use anchor for your
podcast
[Music]